again the best example is coffee 19
think about it
you know you see two patients very
similar clinically
one is getting the disease very mildly
and the other one is dying
what is the difference between those two
patients we see nothing in the blood
test we see nothing in the imaging
okay the difference between these two
patients is probably the way the body is
responding to the disease to the
infection
it's a very complex interplay it's very
complex to decipher
but it's there and we should go there
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lomitech and
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance opposed hillel stanford leap
and birthright excel
welcome to another episode of 20 minute
leaders today i'm with dr offer charon
the ceo of oncohost
dr office charon is a physician and
entrepreneur with more than 20 years of
experience in clinical research
pharmaceuticals and biotechnology and
has made vital contributions to the
acceleration of personalized medicine
and oncology drug development a former
merck executive offers the current ceo
of uncohost a global leader in host
response profiling for improved
personalized cancer therapy
doctor offers welcome to 20 minute
leaders how are you today
i'm good and thanks for having me you're
my kid
thank you very very much for being here
i you know i'll always you know take
every opportunity to speak with an
entrepreneur that is working on
something that is literally saving and
improving people's lives i can't think
of many things more meaningful
than working on cancer therapy and
cancer as a problem as a whole and i can
only imagine you know the impact that
you may that you have on on people that
you know are coming to interaction with
unco host the company that you're the
ceo of so i'm you know i'm excited to
hear both your journey but also take a
step back and understand the world of
cancer a little bit better and
specifically from the angle of cancer
therapy and and how you view it so dr
maybe take me back a little bit you know
briefly throughout your career
through the different experiences what
led to you wanting to start a company in
the cancer therapy space
sure i'd be happy to so you know i spent
the last 20 years in the industry in in
different roles i would say about
two-thirds of the time as an
entrepreneur and then the rest um
working in with four pharma companies
and and
when i started my my journey i was
touching different things i mean there
was always a common theme it was always
a combination of mathematics machine
learning we used to call it in the past
big data
with medicine
but i actually didn't touch on oncology
until i was working for milk foreign i
was the head of medical affairs here in
israel
and i was doing some
a global work dealing with one of the
biggest promises of oncology in the last
i would say 10 to 15 years and that is
immunotherapy and specifically for me
for mercuta and we used to say that you
know a drug like etruda or the
competitors of ketula immunotherapy as a
class is something that you meet once in
a lifetime really and when when we began
the journey
um we were amazed by the initial results
and we really thought that we found a
single bullet now incidentally
uh while i was working on the clinical
trials of ketroda
my father-in-law
got sick with stage four melanoma
and back back then you know being
diagnosed with it with a stage four
melanoma meant usually that year the
patient will die within four five six
months
a
deadly disease not a lot you can do
some people in israel actually
intellectually did some amazing things
with professor
garnier
but still
daily disease without a lot of hope and
and we were struggling very hard to try
and bring my father in love or or keep
him alive until we launched questruda to
the market
and we missed we missed in about three
three months he passed away
unfortunately three months before we had
access to to ketuda and for me that that
was a life-changing event you know
because of many reasons but
one of those reasons was the
understanding that when we are dealing
with cancer when we are dealing with
with cancer patients first of all we
don't have a lot of time
right
time is really important here
and and second
a lot of what we do in cancer even today
is based on trial and error
and and that that just drove me crazy i
mean it didn't make sense it didn't make
sense to me that we are treating a 78
year old men and a 45 year old woman the
same way
these are not the same patients yet yeah
yes we're using the same protocols
and indeed the success rates are not
that amazing
so when when i met yuvali once
and he was telling me about what he's
doing for me it was like an eye opener
and said okay this is this is where i
want to be now
and this is what i want incredible
tell me a little bit about what that is
so all cost is dealing with precision
medicine now when you say precision
medicine and i get it a lot to people
they say oh of course precision medicine
like 500 companies out there doing
precision medicine
but really this is not the case you know
precision medicine is something that is
very very old very very early on in
development
in companies that uh
oh oh scientists that started started
mapping the dna and
found what we call today that having
mutations mutations that are actually
driving cancer go off and spread
we don't have a lot of those
unfortunately
um you can find like something like 6 to
10 depending on how look at that look at
those in in lung cancer
again in the very low numbers below 10
in other cancer indications
so precision medicine
as such is is a very early stage and
it's very similar to
the way we did um
prenatal screening 20 years ago you know
there are 5 000 potential
genetic diseases you know about five
mutations and you test for those
similar to to what we have in oncology
today and this is just you know the tip
of the iceberg
because cancer is a very complex
biological system very complex
biological disease
and the interaction between the patient
the tumor
and the developing
is something that plays a key role in
resistance mechanisms key role in how
our patient is going to respond to
therapy
and what is the prognosis for the
patient
and what i liked about encouraged and
about the science behind it is exactly
the holistic approach
the ability to look both way very much
downstream namely look at proteins
not at the dna level not even at the rna
level
we are looking at examining proteins
second we are not looking at a single
axis or a b dimensional interaction
between therapy and tumor
we are looking at a very complex
interaction between the human body
the cancer
which is in hybrid entity you know
on one side it is part of the body on
the other side it is foreign to the body
and then the therapy
and that complexity and that holistic
approach is what drew me to the concept
from the get-go
so what what what kind of theme is this
you know if we if we were to extrapolate
on this in in the medicine world
what what kind of theme does this act on
so what what is this you know what is
sort of the parallel this and other
examples or
how is this an example of where we're
going to be heading with medicine you
know in the coming years you're dealing
specifically with cancer therapy is this
is this applicable to a greater trend
that we might see in medicine in general
i think it is i think that precision
medicine as such is going to be
the the next wave in in in medicine
because we understand today
that you know um the the disease that we
see
and i think that kovid 19 by the way is
a great example of that
the disease we see the illness that we
see
is not the interaction a
aim between one cause and one effect
it's a complex interplay of biological
process our body is responding
to the disease our body is responding to
therapy
if we will know how to map this
interaction if we know how to look at
this from different angles
not only from the
a cause and effect but look at the
entire
story i think we'll be able to learn
much more about the disease the disease
processes not only in oncology yeah
oncology of course is a huge ultimate
need but i think that also in autoimmune
diseases and inflammatory processes that
the body is undergoing
and i think that
again the best example is coffee 19
think about it
you know you see two patients very
similar clinically
one is getting the disease very mildly
and the other one is dying what is the
difference between those two patients we
see nothing in the blood test we see
nothing in the imaging
okay the difference between these two
patients is probably the way the body is
responding to the disease to the
infection
it's a very complex interplay it's very
complex to decipher
but it's there and we should go there
i think that they
i always liked it
i like to use the example of the
navigation systems in the past you know
when i was a kid and you were traveling
in europe you had this green book the
michelin book book of maps and i
remember my mother sitting in in in the
in the shotgun seat and yelling at my
father this is not the right text if you
should go this you know
and we were planning our trips based on
those maps
uh the next stage we had the navigation
the the simple unification system that
we had in the cars bulky bulky products
and then came waze
which is a learning system that actually
can tell you when you're going to arrive
at your destination which way you should
choose
and i think that precision medicine is
going exactly that way you know right
now we are using the paper maps
the next stage is going to be the
navigation system but then moving
forward
i think that
the journey of the patient through the
cancer is going to be a very
personalized one
wow and so if you're looking at you know
this endeavor and a very very very
worthwhile mission what what is sort of
the the greatest challenger is it more
that the technology is it more you know
the the whole you know the understanding
of the whole market that this is where
you know the incentives should be and
this is where the the you know the the
in you know the
personal
you know endeavors should be what what
is this what are the challenges here
i think that the biggest challenges of
the the traditional or the the the
conservative perception of
disease and
in medicine that we have in in the
western medicine in general
and i'll explain we are used to look for
very specific cause and effects i have a
pneumonia let's find the bacteria i have
an upper respiratory board let's find a
virus
cancer is different
cancer is not the same disease
autoimmune diseases are different
you don't you you can't always find you
know one single
entity to accuse of the disease
cancer is complex it's not always
homogenic in nature so one cancer cell
doesn't necessarily
resemble the other one we have
we have in the same two more different
kinds of cancer cells
and i think it's very hard for us you
know coming from the the western
concepts of of medicine to to perceive
that and to accept the fact that this is
not
we won't find a silver bullet for cancer
we are not going to find the antibiotic
that is going to kill all cancer types
we need to start dig much deeper
and
reach much higher resolutions i think
this is one big challenge
it is challenge on the size of the
investors
it is a challenge on the sides of the
pharma companies
that are used to this model of let's
come with a drug
sell a drug to a disease
make a lot of money
bring good to our patients
and the concept here is very different
if we look at a cancer patient and
clinician will tell you that
when you see a cancer patient before you
start treatment early on treatment and
then six months into therapy this is not
the same patient
things are changing
and i think that this change in
perception is one big challenge and this
challenge expresses itself in many
different way first of all it's going to
be hard to educate the physicians
educate the market
that this is what you need to do second
the investors you know
we see a lot of investments going
it's always this kind of held approach
we're going in the same direction
so while you in the academy in academic
meetings you hear people talking today
about host response and immune response
and the relation between those and
cancer response
in the investments that you see out
there people are still investing in ngs
in next generation sequencing in
mutations
now there's always this disconnect which
is for companies like us always a
challenge because you need to investor
investors to invest
in something that doesn't exist yet
and to find those investors i can tell
you it's a challenge
so now for more of a leadership
perspective you know having gone into
this journey more from
a personal experience you know what what
does it mean to you what what are what
are you learning about yourself as you
as you're running this company and as
you're working on something that is
obviously so deeply meaningful to you
you know it's it's
it's a complex question i i think that
you know this is not my first company
and um
when when i enlisted to the army and my
commander told me
before we had the
you know one of those big
uh massage i can't recall
you will be able to do that and in the
end
you you won't believe that you did it
but you will do it and i think that
running a company is very similar
you know
new challenges all around you
getting the money to find the company
finding the right people
dealing with the technology of course
challenge dealing with regulatory issues
dealing with
a um
with your ongoing or ever-changing
go-to-market strategy
we are in a very complex environment and
i think that what i learned about myself
that i'm much more resilient than i
thought at the beginning you know
really yeah i mean i still you sleep at
night
about this so many things
um
but you know the next day comes and you
do what you need to do and sometimes i
tell my team
that
we have the best job in the world you
know until lunch we solve problems that
people are not dealing with um
during their entire life
and i think that this this is amazing
though so the journey is amazing it is a
very hard one
i when i learned about myself i'm very
resilient and i have a very strong
driving force you know
uh i feel that in a way kind of failed
you know with my father-in-law
wasn't able to make it uh which was of
course a big disappointment for my wife
his daughter
and for me on course is kind of a way to
um
wow
you know
ethical
i can only imagine the the intrinsic
motivation that that comes with an
experience like this and and and the way
that then you lead this company not from
a place of simply innovation and simply
uh you know a financial return but with
a deep sense of meaning and and knowing
with this very strong conviction inside
why you're doing what you're doing and
what is the vision and and how you're
going to be helping people's lives now
if you go back a little bit you know
previously before this company and even
your childhood you know what really
fascinates you is it is it always in the
world of health is it always in the in
the world of innovation or were you
involved with with things that are
different than this
you know from
even as a kid from
from by the time i remember i i was i
was into medicine
uh into biology into medicine this was
always my preference
uh
starting with the my fish tank in in the
room when i when i when i was a kid in
in animals and then
um being a
in the army going to going to be a medic
and
yeah i was always into medicine i was
always amazed
by the complexity
the
the immune system is something that was
you know i i remember as
as a young adult very young adult while
i was in the army reading a book about
the immune system a textbook about the
immune system because really
fascinated by that
so i was always drawn to to this i think
that in recent years
and when i say recent i'm talking about
the last 10 to 15 years my taste changed
and i was
and and today my fascination
is the combination between mathematics
machine learning big data
in medicine and in the potential
application of of that and what that
that might carry for the future
i i love it and so as you're as you're
looking towards you know this phase of
your of your career you know do you see
yourself continuing with this trend of
problem solving whether it's with unco
host or whether it's with any other
company so sort of have you
did this change or this experience
changed the way that you're perceiving
now your mission here and what your
career you wanted to look like
um
you know i i live my dream life really
wow
i got you know
an infinite amount of money to today
i would still go up in and come to the
office tomorrow i can promise you that i
really enjoy what i do amazing i think
that you know
moving forward being being an
entrepreneur and you mentioned that you
are going to be one soon
is is not an easy it's not an easy
a journey and i'm almost reaching 50
soon
i'm not sure that i will want to be you
know
another ceo of another company and then
another company
again and the taste in a way might
change as well here
and then maybe the next step is going to
be investments
i love it what are your thoughts
yes
what are a few words that you would use
to describe yourself or if i were to ask
anybody around you how would they
describe it also shalon
oh my god i'm not sure i won't i want to
i want you to ask this question you know
what i i think that
and i heard it from from several people
already i'm i'm this
little type you know people follow me
and they say that they follow me and
some of the people i work with actually
continue from other companies as well
yeah
not not very i want to say friendly but
i tend to be tough
but only only when when it comes to
to professionalism
and i think we know we we have no room
for for mistakes we have no room for
a cutting corners in what we do
people are expecting us to bring the
best possible science to them to the
patients and we have a lot of patients
right talking to us
so i think that people will say that
offer is a
maybe a tough cookie sometimes but
easily though
i i love it oh phil thank you so much
and i can you know obviously we're not
talking about a traditional startup in
another product we're talking about
something that is actually you know it
can be the difference between life and
death or the or the way that somebody
lives their life and the way that they
they deal with this uncertainty and this
most difficult thing that i can imagine
and so i really first of all appreciate
your work and i'm inspired by your
personal journey and and and the the
deep intrinsic motivation that you have
to do what you do i think that's just
incredible and that's what at the end
we're all looking for and so thank you
very much for taking the time to to
share with me this journey and continue
making a positive impact stay safe and
stay healthy
thank you thank you very much michael i
appreciate it
good luck with your journey
thank you
you